ann air was a student in her early 20s
when she went with her friends to watch
liverpool play nottingham forest
in the 1989 fa cup semi-final at
hillsborough
she and thousands of other fans had no
idea that it would become the worst
disaster in british sporting history
and would continue to affect her to this
day time is not only
not a healer time actually has made it
worse
for many of us now south yorkshire and
west midlands police forces have agreed
to pay damages to 601 people
after a cover-up in the aftermath of the
tragedy in which 96 liverpool fans died
and was one of the lucky ones pulled out
of pen three
of the now infamous leppings lane stand
when the fatal crush
started there was the trauma of the day
but the cover-up
i would say for many of us i can speak
personally was almost a much
bigger challenge to deal with and
survivor guilt sadly for some
some of my my friends and others that
we're in touch with the survivors has
even proved fatal
it's so difficult to live with the
ongoing guilt and having been blamed
even though we knew that we were not
responsible
nobody has ever been convicted over the
cover-up and although this civil claim
was agreed back in april
it's only been made public now after the
trial of former south yorkshire police
officers donald denton and alan foster
and peter metcalfe the force's lawyer at
the time had finished
the three men were accused of amending
police officers statements
to minimize blame but were acquitted
last week
after a judge ruled there was no case to
answer
in a statement south yorkshire police
said we acknowledge that
serious errors and mistakes were made by
south yorkshire police
both on the 15th of april 1989 and
during the subsequent investigations
some of the victims families would still
prefer successful prosecutions to pay
outs
others say the payments are insulting
and the process to get them
was humiliating however those who
negotiated it
hope the settlement will have a positive
effect by providing funding for
psychiatric counselling
and support nothing can compensate the
families for
everything they've been through and the
long
hard fight for justice over the last 30
years
a fight that they should never have been
made to bring
despite the numerous and often cruel
setbacks of a 32-year fight for justice
the 96 victims are always remembered
fraser moored sky news